[Applause]
Jason Jason boss it's like looking in a
mirror
Oh
it's all good have a seat have a seat
mc2 procedure finally reunited with your
wives to be but we now discover you know
everybody
you've met Regina Belle oh yes yes my
wife yes so many people we have six
degrees both in the DC Universe you know
yo yeah I know I know yeah look he's
here as well yeah yeah yeah this is this
is essentially what you would look like
if you were chopped off at the knees and
never went to the gym
[Laughter]
did you take this as a warning
annoyed you'd be on set anyway you stunt
doubles here
really
Jason Emily you have seen each other
since Game of Thrones every time I come
to England oh I just remembered so
because this goes out we're taping this
on a Thursday so this goes out tomorrow
night yes
so will you tomorrow night so when we
went to be here we'll be at my party it
will be us for party do you want to I'd
love to come as long as mystic and swap
clothes and I turn up first
[Applause]
Oh Ross is so
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh sure what is this coat is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that might be done for this cat food in
the park
[Music]